la guerre en Ukraine Kiev revendique
aujourd'hui la conquête de position sur
la rive gauche du nièpre occupée par les
Russes dans le sud du pays premier
succès d'importance après des mois d'une
contre-offensive poussive on va
rejoindre tout de suite àni Rifka non
loin de mikolaiv et de rerson notre
envoyé spécial Emmanuel Chaz bonjour
Emmanuel après je le disais des mois de
difficultés pour l'armée ukrainienne
voici donc une avancée importante qui
pourrait permettre un assaut plus
important par la suite vers le
sud
bonjour ahren oui tout à fait c'est une
c'est une c'est une annonce qui est qui
a son importance ici en Ukraine puisque
cela faisait des mois que l'armée
ukrainienne tentait de franchir le dpro
et comme la rive qui est occupé par les
Russes et bien elle est défendue c'est
très difficile de poser de d'établir des
troupes de l'autre côté alors il y a eu
des incursion depuis le mois de février
elles se sont intensifié au mois d'août
mais là on a une confirmation on a une
une double confirmation d'une part c'est
la première fois que l'armée russe
confirme qu'il y a bien une implantation
ukrainienne de l'autre côté du Nipro et
d'autre part on a cette confirmation de
la part de l'Ukraine notamment de la
part des forces des forces maritimes de
l'Ukraine qui annonc avoir effectivement
s'être effectivement implanté dans
plusieurs endroits alors l'importance
ici c'est que ça pourrait permettre à
l'armée ukrainienne de faire passer plus
de troupes de faire passer plus
d'équipant et si cela est effectivement
possible mais il ne faut pas oublier que
l'armée russe et bien elle a l'avantage
des air elle domine par les aires elle
peut donc plus facilement attaquer cette
armée ukrainienne mais si toutefois Kiev
parvient à faire passer ce matériel et
bien ça pourrait être très significatif
pour la suite de la contreoffensive qui
vous l'avez dit avait plutôt patiné ces
derniers mois et pendant ce temps
Emmanuel Kiev continue d'alerter sur la
nécessité de ne pas oublier l'aide à
l'Ukraine malgré le contexte que l'on
connaît au ProcheOrient
tout à fait d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensk a signalé
que depuis depuis le début de la guerre
entre Israël et le Hamas et bien il y
avait beaucoup moins d'armes qui étaient
délivré et notamment des munitions qui
étaient délivrées à l'Ukraine alors on a
entendu plusieurs partenaires
occidentaux de l'Ukraine dire depuis le
7 octobre que la guerre au ProcheOrient
ne changerait rien pour l'Ukraine sauf
que de fait ça change quelque chose sur
le terrain un moment où l'Ukraine a de
plus en plus besoin de cet équipement
notamment pour continuer cette
contreoffensive mais pas seulement aussi
pour se défendre notamment contre les
attaques aériennes ici dans la région de
mikolayev on est juste à côté de celle
de kson et bien les alertes elles
sonnent tous les jours et dans la région
de Helson il y a des bombardements
quotidiens aujourd'hui trois personnes
sont mortes dans des bombardements à
hson puisque c'est une ville qui est
très exposée elle est au bord du fleuve
Nipro donc en en direct vis-à-vis des
troupes russes c'est c'est c'est pour ça
notamment euh que c'est CR que c'est
crucial pour les troupes ukrainienne de
déloger euh l'occupant russe de cette
rive aussi pour protéger leur Riv Rin
merci beaucoup Emmanuel pour ces
précisions depuis SNI Rivka en Ukraine